sirvas de ver todo el vídeo antes de
revisar la circulación sanguínea en su
pierna
este video le enseñará Cómo revisar la
circulación sanguínea en su pierna una
buena circulación sanguínea es
importante para la recuperación después
del procedimiento quirúrgico en su
pierna
paso 1 revise el pie y los dedos de la
pierna que se está recuperando del
procedimiento quirúrgico
compare sus pies nota alguna diferencia
el pie y los dedos en el lado quirúrgico
deben estar tibios de color normal y
presentar poca o ninguna hinchazón
estos signos significan que usted tiene
una buena circulación sanguínea en la
pierna
Si supiese ves rojo o Azul se siente
frío o está muy hinchado su pierna puede
tener mala circulación sanguínea
paso 2 siente entumecimiento u hormigueo
en el pie una sensación de
entumecimiento u hormigueo también puede
ser síntomas de mala circulación
sanguínea
o también puede sentir el entumecimiento
por un tipo de anestesia llamada bloqueo
de nervio hasta que desaparezca su
efecto
si no está seguro si le aplicaron un
bloqueo de nervio consulte con su
cirujano
paso 3 mueva los dedos de sus pies al
mover los dedos del pie mejora la
circulación sanguínea del pie
[Música]
repita los pasos uno al tres cada cuatro
horas o según lo indicado por su
cirujano
otra manera de comprobar si tiene una
buena circulación sanguínea es haciendo
la prueba del llenado capilar
los capilares son vasos sanguíneos
pequeños que llevan la sangre rica en
oxígeno hasta los dedos de sus pies la
prueba del llenado capilar le permite
ver que también circula la sangre a
través de estos vasos sanguíneos a sus
dedos del pie en el lado quirúrgico
[Música]
paso 1 pellizque suavemente la punta del
dedo del pie directamente sobre la uña
con su mano paso 2 pellizque hasta que
la uña del dedo del pie se ponga blanca
y luego suelte la uña del dedo del pie
debe ponerse nuevamente rosada en el
lapso de dos o tres segundos este signo
significa que usted tiene una buena
circulación sanguínea en su pierna y pie
repita los pasos 1 al 2 cada 4 horas o
según lo indicado por su cirujano
[Música]
comuníquese con su cirujano si nota que
su pie se pone rojo o Azul
se ve muy hinchado
se siente frío entumecido o con
hormigueo A menos que le hayan realizado
un bloqueo de nervio durante la cirugía
lo que hace que su pie se sienta
entumecido hasta que pase el efecto o
que su uña del pie demore más de 2 a 3
segundos en retornar a su color rosado
al hacer la prueba del llenado capilar